having what can make a difference in
Africa is ensuring that there is green
water all over the place in every
village every municipality that
everybody has to has access to promote
me what does this does is to ensure that
the people the population in that
particular area enjoys good health if
they enjoy good health they'll be able
to send their children to school they'll
be able to engage in a profitable
economic activity so most of Africa does
not have water and if that can be a
priority for governments then a lot of
problems a lot of challenges would be
addressed it means hospitals who have a
lesser pageant was most of the diseases
are waterborne in most villages in
Africa and therefore you are deliciously
they drug the drug budget you are
improving education kid I would go to
school everything and therefore do well
in school and in a very health
population issuers development so I
think water there is a paramount for me